you first learn about american history
it sometimes seems like it might have
been a very easy or somewhat obvious
transition from the articles of
confederation to the constitution but it
was not it was a very vigorous debate as
we've talked about in previous videos
the articles of confederation proves to
be too weak in terms of a central
government you have events like shae's
rebellion which really highlights this
and then as we go into
1787 you have a constitutional
convention at first to maybe revise the
articles of confederation but eventually
they draft a completely new constitution
the constitution that we have today
and after it was drafted after that
convention we get into this period of
late 1787 and 1788 where you have this
very vigorous debate between those who
want to ratify the constitution often
known as the federalists led by folks
like alexander hamilton james madison
john jay famous for writing the
federalist papers which they publish in
this time frame and you also have the
anti-federalists or who will eventually
be known as the anti-federalists who are
against the ratification and the
adoption of the constitution and their
writings which are also published in
this same time period are known as now
the anti-federalist papers and what i
have here is an excerpt from what is
perhaps the most famous of the
anti-federalist papers this is from
brutus one published on the 18th of
october 1787 so right in this time
period right over here right after the
constitutional convention had ended and
the states were deciding whether to
ratify it and brutus is the pen name of
the author it's believed to either be
robert yates melangton smith or john
williams from new york but the reason
why they picked the name brutus is from
history brutus is the roman senator who
was involved in assassinating julius
caesar keeping him from overthrowing the
republic so in some ways they view
themselves as people who are protecting
the republic from tyranny now as i read
this keep in mind some of the ideas that
we've looked at in other videos the
different types of democracy a
participatory democracy where the
citizens are close to the governance to
the decision-making you have a pluralist
democracy where you have
a vigorous debate between many many
different views and you have an idea of
an elite democracy where the people are
still sovereign but they're being
represented by a smaller limited group
of i guess you could say elite maybe
more wealthy more educated folks who are
trying or who should be acting in the
interests of the citizens so keep those
in mind and think about what type of
democracy the author here favors and
what they might be afraid of
and so brutus wrote to the citizens of
the state of new york
the first question that presents itself
on the subject is
whether the 13 united states should be
reduced to one great republic governed
by one legislature and under the
direction of one executive and judicial
or whether they should continue 13
confederated republics under the
direction control of a supreme federal
head for certain defined national
purposes only so they're starting with
this argument that this new constitution
was really creating just one supreme
government instead of a confederation of
sovereign republics that coordinate for
certain defined national purposes he
goes on to write this government is to
possess absolute and uncontrollable
power legislative executive and judicial
with respect to every object to which it
extends
the powers of the general legislature so
they're talking about what would
eventually be the u.s congress as
proposed by the constitution extend to
every case that is of the least
importance there is nothing valuable to
human nature nothing dear to free men
but what is within its power it has the
authority to make laws which will affect
the lives the liberty and property of
every man in the united states nor can
the constitution or laws of any state in
any way prevent or impede the full and
complete execution of every power given
so once again saying hey this is a
takeover these 13 states are really
becoming one state under the
constitution this central government has
so much power that it kind of makes the
states a little bit irrelevant because
they can't do something outside of what
the central government thinks they
should do
so then having established this argument
and once again this is just an excerpt i
encourage you to read all of brutus one
it's quite fascinating the author then
argues why this is a bad idea to have
this takeover and have 13 sovereign
states turn into essentially one
let us now proceed to inquire as i at
first proposed whether it be best the 13
united states should be reduced to one
great republic or not
history furnishes no example of a free
republic anything like the extent of the
united states the grecian republics were
of small extent so also was that of the
romans both of these it is true in
process of time extended their conquests
over large territories of country and
the consequence was that their
governments were changed from that of
free governments to those of the most
tyrannical that ever existed in the
world so saying hey look there's really
no precedent for this when you just had
the athenians governing themselves in a
participatory model yes a republic
seemed to work but then once it started
to extend its influence over surrounding
cities around around the surrounding
regions it became more tyrannical and
the romans even more so
the territory of the united states is of
vast extent it now contains near 3
millions of souls and is capable of
containing much more than 10 times that
number these might not seem like big
numbers now the united states is today
over a hundred times bigger but this was
already quite a bit larger than say just
ancient athens
is it practicable for a country so large
and so numerous as they will soon become
to elect a representation that will
speak their sentiments without their
becoming so numerous as to be incapable
of transacting public business it
certainly is not so this is really
interesting so to the founding fathers
the idea of a republic was really a
representative democracy and brutus here
is questioning look if you if you're
governing over such a vast territory can
you have a representation that will
truly speak the sentiments of the people
and if you do have true representation
of the people well are you going to have
so many representatives and so many
interests that they're not going to be
able to govern so he's saying hey this
is going to be
pluralist
and he does not view pluralism as a good
thing he's saying hey there's going to
be so many views this is going to be
ungovernable
in a republic the manners sentiments and
interests of the people should be
similar so this is worth underlining
again because this is a statement
directly against the notion of pluralism
he says in order for a republic to work
you have to have people of similar
sentiments and interests not different
views if this be not the case there will
be a constant clashing of opinions and
the representatives of one part will be
continually striving against those of
the others who clearly did not think
much of a pluralist democracy this will
the operations of government and
prevent such conclusions as will
promote the public good so he sees
pluralism as a recipe for indecision and
not being able to pass good laws or do
things in the public interest
he goes on to say
in so extensive our republic the great
officers of government would soon become
above the control of the people and
abuse their power to the purpose of
aggrandizing themselves and oppressing
them so here it looks like the author is
afraid of you could kind of say an elite
democracy that it really wouldn't even
be a republic that these people are
going to start acting in their own
interests if you have to have
representatives that represent such a
large territory they're going to be
detached from the people that they're
representing and then are just going to
think about their own aggrandization and
they will actually oppress the people
that they're supposed to represent
these are some of the reasons by which
it appears that a free republic cannot
long subsist over a country of the great
extent of these states
if then this new constitution is
calculated to consolidate the 13 states
into one as it evidently is it ought not
to be adopted so brutus is making this
argument that look you can't have a
republic over such a vast territory
arguably the states are a little bit
more tractable although even at this
point some of the large states are quite
large but they would have a better
chance of being a free republic than
merging all of the 13 states into what
would effectively be one republic